[Applaudissements]
on me signale en régie que chacun
d'entre vous va devoir raconter une
anecdote comme ça l esi ça tombe sur
vous et nora vous êtes à part vous
adorer ça d'avoir pu me passer de
nouvelles îles et la chance parce que je
suis pas sûr que si et quand à neuf du
couche avec une hotte à côté qu'elles
soient d'accord mais qui vient juste de
raconter qu'il a fait un plan à trois là
la vie un des ennemis est scooté dans
ces cas-là et et autant laisser parler
un expert moscou lors de ces amateurs il
ya quelqu'un sur ce plateau que payer
pour ça allez-y non mais moi je vais
raconter comment je racontais ma femme
c'est ça j'étais jeune journaliste alice
le bic a annoncé l ordre des cigarettes
et audoises hôtesses gold bondit de
fumée les cuves la gueule et du cou
là il chauffe et vous voulez vous qu'ils
louent les portes à frazer
et voilà je suis tombé à vous j'ai eu un
flash tombe amoureux d'elle tout de
suite j'ai habité à paris il est
raccompagnée en voiture dans l'ancien à
paris et je suis plus jamais retourner à
nancy ils m'ont appelé le lendemain au
boulot énorme été ou qui je suis à paris
quand as tu reviens je ne reviendrai pas
je reste l'appareil qu'est-ce qui se
masque élevé entité complètement
indépendante et ça fait du bien de voir
qu'ils vécurent y aller mais tellement
peu de qui ne veut que j'annonce de
trois dates pour le remercier quand même
d'être venu dans ce jour particulier il
y à un grand événement c'est le bel 6
avril au zénith de paris le 29 avril
orléans vainqueur de toulouse 29 mai
montpelliérain terme et bordeaux